foreign
on this Sunday night a plan for equity
and inclusion we need to continue to
stand up to show what a truly positive
inclusive
strong society looks like Canada unveils
its first ever action plan for 2s lgbtqi
plus communities the campaign kicks off
Quebec's 43rd general election begins
with controversial policies at stake and
the latest in the Trump FBI search saga
this is disgusting in my mind no
President should act this way the move
to appoint an independent attorney to
review the records taken from his
Mar-A-Lago home plus the plunge that
took a top prize
Canada's performance at the cliff diving
World Series
global national with Fara Nasser
reporting tonight Tracy Tom
good evening and thanks so much for
joining us in an announcement time to
coincide with ottawa's pride events the
federal government has unveiled the
country's first ever 2s lgbtqi plus
action plan the plan includes 100
million dollars in spending over the
next five years with most of the money
to go to Grassroots groups aimed at
helping people in their communities as
Nathaniel Dove reports the investment
comes as the country has been seeing a
significant multi-year uptick in reports
of sexual orientation motivated crime
a celebration of who you are and whom
you love on Sunday the federal
government unveiled its long-awaited
action plan designed to address the
inequality and discrimination
lgbtq2 people face
happy Pride
among other things the plan aims to
embed two
slgbtqi plus issues in all government
work continue to advance rights at home
and abroad and prioritize Community
Action that includes up to 75 million
dollars in funding for local
organizations in the next five years
this is a whole of government plan that
will guide our ongoing work to fight
discrimination to break down barriers it
comes during a more threatening time for
lgbtq people hate crimes motivated by
sexual orientation have more than
doubled in the past five years from 204
in 2017 to 423 last year and that number
jumped up 64 percent between 2020 and
2021 and lgbtq advocate in Saskatchewan
says they're seeing more discrimination
like hateful graffiti last June during
the province's pride month
you know there isn't a day where I don't
you know go out to my car and and do a
check to see if Something's Happened
Queen City Pride co-chair Dan Shire
welcomes the new plan saying it could be
a foundational step but where the plant
looks at data collection he wants
stronger action make crimes towards our
community uh is addressed through
um more uh action more visibility and
for me more education so a positive step
but there is still a long way to go
before people can be who they are
without fear
Nathaniel Dove Global News Saskatoon
prime minister Justin Trudeau condemned
the rising trend of harassment against
politicians in Canada and against women
and racialized communities following a
tirade of verbal abuse leveled at
Christa Freeland while the Deputy Prime
Minister visited her home province of
Alberta on Friday
As Leaders we need to call this out and
take a United stance against it because
no matter who you are who you love the
color of your skin how you pray where
you're from your gender you deserve
respect and you deserve to live in peace
without fear of threats or violence
now police say they are aware of this
widely circulated video of the attack
which shows a man walking towards
Freeland while she was waiting in the
lobby of the Grand Prairie City Hall
then yelling profanities at her and
calling Freeland a traitor now
Christopher Freeland is from Peace River
in Alberta and said in a statement what
happened was wrong nobody anywhere
should have to put up with threats and
intimidation
Quebec's political parties are now in
high gear after a Francois Lago met with
the lieutenant governor today to
officially kick off the province's
election campaign voters will make their
choice on October 3rd and it's a race
that seemingly Legos to lose with his
governing caq party holding a commanding
lead in the early polls Tim Sargent has
more on what to expect
with that signature Quebec's lieutenant
governor formally dissolved the National
Assembly marking an end to the 42nd
legislature and officially launching a
36-day election campaign quebecers will
be heading to the polls October 3rd
our ncaq leader Francois Lago kicked off
his re-election bid in Quebec City
flanked by some of his candidates what I
repeat to my team about everything is
don't take anything for granted at the
time the legislature ended its session
the governing caq party held a strong
majority with 76 seats of 125 the
Liberals Quebec solidar the party
quebecois the conservative party of
Quebec and four Independents all Trail
far behind Lego is seeking a second
straight majority I think that everybody
has to look first at our track record
but the leaders of the four major
political parties challenging Lego are
going after his record especially on the
economy ask any quebecer whether they're
better off today than they were four
years ago and they'll answer the
question by no Dominic onglad is
attacking Lago for not doing enough to
end the ongoing labor shortage and not
containing the rising costs of living a
similar argument being made by the
leader of Quebec solider
is it normal in 2022 that people that
have a job a full-time job isn't able to
pay
the groceries and the rent at the end of
the month it is not normal and the
leader of Quebec's conservative party is
focusing on tax cuts we need to do just
like Ontario did a few weeks ago and
suspend the attacks on gas
but Lago has a commanding lead in the
most recent polls and he's already
spelling out his campaign priorities
focusing on the economy education
environment Healthcare and national
identity I think that they are
vulnerabilities for the caq on all the
issues this McGill professor says the
four other party leaders will have
plenty of opportunities to challenge
Lego for coming out on top won't be easy
this kind of division of the opposition
helps the caq ultimately leaders of the
four other major parties and their
candidates are hoping to take advantage
of any mistakes if they're made by the
caq knowing that this campaign for now
is more of a marathon rather than a
Sprint Tim's search Global comes from
Montreal
in the U.S a federal judge has announced
her intention to Grant former president
Donald Trump's request for an
independent special Master to review
boxes of classified documents and other
materials taken in that FBI raid of
Trump's Mar-A-Lago estate Trump says the
raid was politically motivated now
Republicans are applauding the move but
as Jennifer Johnson reports Democrats
say it won't matter as the investigation
will continue
you have a word after weeks of
eye-opening headlines lawyers for former
president Donald Trump may have scored a
win a U.S District Judge appointed by
Trump has indicated she will allow an
independent review of some materials
confiscated at Trump's Florida estate
good thing they're going to have a
special Master look at these documents
for understanding turned over a lot of
documents he should have turned over all
of them I imagine he knows that very
well now as well the judges specified
the review will focus primarily on
documents involving attorney-client
privilege that were taken along with
boxes of top secret material those
highly sensitive papers will not be part
of the review most Republicans are still
decrying the FBI's raid but not all of
them the hypocrisy of folks in my party
that spent years chanting lock her up
about Hillary Clinton because of some
deleted emails or quote unquote wiping a
server are now out there defending a man
who very clearly did not take the
National Security of the United States
to heart that Department of Justice and
the U.S Director of National
Intelligence are now working together to
review the top secret materials to
determine if they resulted in any
security breaches that could harm
America or its intelligence workers do
we have confidential human sources at
risk do we have intelligent intelligence
collection Methods at risk that our
adversaries might now be able to to
learn about if they obtain these
documents
what remains unknown is why Trump took
documents containing some of America's
most sensitive secrets to an unsecure
location the potential penalties for
Trump would be unprecedented court
documents unsealed last week revealed
the justice department is investigating
violations of the presidential records
act the Espionage Act and obstruction of
justice
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in Pakistan the death toll from the
country's ongoing flooding disaster is
climbing
more than 1 000 people are now known to
have died since the flooding began
mid-june raging flash floods triggered
by torrential rain have Swept Away
houses restaurants and bridges half of
the country is underwater millions of
people are displaced Schools and
Government buildings are being converted
into shelter camps that house locals
being airlifted to safety
in Libya the U.N is urging for a
ceasefire in the country's capital after
some of the deadliest fighting in two
years more than 30 people are dead after
gunfights and artillery struck
neighborhoods and hospitals across the
city on Saturday it all stems from
fighting between the recognized
government's military and militia forces
of a rival group vying for control of
the country
well since the Russian invasion began
just over six months ago countless
Grassroots organizations have sprung up
across Canada raising funds and
collecting supplies to help the
Ukrainian cause in BC One group has
spent the past few weeks Gathering
supplies and packing a shipping
container destined to help those in the
war-torn region Paul Johnson reports
there's 35 kilos on that and that bed's
going in if you follow the news about
Ukraine at all you'll know that since
the war started Canadians have gathered
and shipped a river of supplies to the
battlefields and to Ukraine's
overwhelmed institutions what's
happening today is we're we're figuring
out exactly what needs to go directly by
shipping container in a donated space on
an Abbotsford Farm Saturday we caught up
with John Lowe a military veteran of
Afghanistan he's now a walking example
of Canada's Aid movement for Ukraine
he's personally delivered suitcases full
of expensive items to the country now
he's quarterbacking the loading of this
40-foot container set to ship out Monday
one of the things I realized really
quickly is is their equipment is is
incredibly outdated well Ottawa has
supplied some weapons Canada is just not
in a position to send something like Jan
Javelin missiles so more and more it's
looking like our Legacy will be things
like this Striker hospital beds Advanced
first aid kits even an ultrasound
machine some of it bought much of it
donated
since the war started this is going to
be my third fourth container for years
before the Russian invasion retired
businessman Roman sawicki had been
shipping supplies to Ukraine so he had a
network of contacts in place to move
things swiftly which is another part of
Canada's Aid story much of it is people
to people
self-organizing online sawicki says
ordinary Canadians are making as
meaningful the contribution as any other
country I can't think of another country
that could come close to what Ukraine
with Canada has been sending so Wiki
says there are no fewer than 50
hospitals in Ukraine right now working
with Canadian sourced supplies this
batch will go to Halifax then Poland
much of it will end up near the
Ukrainian front lines
in Abbotsford Paul Johnson Global News
coming up the concerns for pets boarding
planes
well another frustrating day for
travelers with multi-hour lines at
Vancouver International Airport the
congestion due to job action by Casa
security screeners and a resulting staff
shortage some passengers say they were
stuck in line for more than three hours
and numerous people did miss their
flights
and as airports experience delays a
Calgary dog owner is Raising concerns
about the safety of taking pets on
flights she says her pup was left on the
tarmac for almost 30 minutes by WestJet
Cruise during a sweltering summer day
tomasia Da Silva reports
with her thick dark coat it doesn't take
long for Cleo to get overheated
owner Jenna Richardson proger tries her
best to keep her cool but neither She
nor Cleo were able to do that recently
my dog's my child so I I was I was in
tears the tears started at Halifax's
airport the pair were flying home to
Calgary and while Mom was waiting to
board so was Cleo here she is in her
cage on the tarmac at 6 26 pm and there
she goes into the cargo hold at 6 50.
some 30 minutes later in plus 30 degree
heat my mom called it the hottest day of
the summer in Nova Scotia Richardson
proger says Cleo and two others were
kept here while the previous flight
unloaded and when she voiced her concern
to WestJet staff three times they just
said you know the baggage attendants
have it under control don't worry about
it I was so upset seeing her out there I
just knew how hot she she must have felt
and she had no control of the situation
she's stuck there in a crate in
follow-up messages WestJet told her the
agents confirmed your dog was in good
health again we're sorry for the
situation we apologize again on behalf
of baggage handlers we're happy your dog
is okay
WestJet told us it always does its best
to get pets on quickly but it also
doesn't want to get them on too soon it
adds it successfully transports
thousands of animals per year both
through passenger and cargo Services
again Cleo was fine upon arrival oh look
at you and she's obviously fine now but
Jenna Richardson proger worries what
about next time I paid for a service to
have my dog transported safely and if
they can't do that then they shouldn't
they just shouldn't be doing it to
Matthew Da Silva Global News
ahead how another interest rate hike may
push homeowners to their mortgage
trigger point we'll explain stay with us
on September 7th the Bank of Canada will
announce whether another interest rate
hike will be coming and for many
Canadians that decision will have a
major impact on their family finances as
Kamal karamali reports for many
homeowners Rising interest rates could
push them closer to their mortgage
trigger point
as the Bank of Canada continues to hike
interest rates it'll now likely mean
higher monthly payments for variable
rate mortgage holders by Year's End
certainly it's Unique it's very unique
RBC estimates roughly 80 000 variable
mortgages will hit what's called a
trigger rate after quote the next couple
of rate hikes by the Bank of Canada of
those variable mortgages they say it'll
mean an average increase of two hundred
dollars per month the trigger rate is
when you're not making the minimum
required principal payment towards your
mortgage so it's a protection strategy
that the Canadian banks have in place
the best way to calculate your trigger
rate is by multiplying your monthly
payment by the number of payments per
year and then dividing it by the
outstanding mortgage balance for example
if your mortgage balance is five hundred
thousand dollars and you pay twenty two
hundred dollars per month multiplied by
12 months and then divide that by the
amount owed in this case it's five
hundred thousand dollars your trigger
rate would be five point two eight
percent if the bank of Canada's interest
rate goes above that your lender can now
adjust your payment amount even though
it's normally fixed so this trigger rate
ensures that the amortization doesn't go
beyond the original amortization within
the criteria in which they got the
mortgage at that point advisors will
offer one of three options one increase
your monthly payments to switch to a
fixed rate mortgage or three pay a lump
sum there's certainly going to be some
level of pain in the marketplace and
there will be a small small subset of
people that perhaps fell across Hard
Times lost their job were relying on
this payment and they could be in
difficult spot mortgage brokers add
every homeowner with a variable rate
mortgage will have a different trigger
rate so for a more accurate number it's
recommended you call your mortgage
lender Kamal coromali Global News
next going back in time through a camera
lens how a BC man sees the world through
an antique technique
a UNESCO heritage site in Bosnia and
Herzegovina hosted a leg of Red Bull's
cliff diving World Series and the
athletes twisted and spun as they
plummeted 21 meters off the starry most
Bridge
23-year-old Canadian Molly Carlson took
second place in the women's division at
the event and stands at second overall
for the season so far
all right on to a calmer hobby now these
days technology allows us to quickly
Snap photos or videos with our phones
it's also just as easy to share them but
that's not the case for one BC
photographer who's traveling around in
an RV that doubles as his dark room
that's because he's using an antique
technique that requires a lot of things
and a lot more patience
Jay Durant explains why
there is a lot of work to do before
framing a first shot a little bit hard
some heavy lifting for Bill Howe and his
wife Crystal all
we're almost there they're setting up
this massive camera Bill spent two years
creating
all for a very specific type of
photography invented in the 1850s the
white plate clothing is a
looks so cool so much for point and
shoot Bill's passion for capturing the
perfect picture is a little more
involved and I work here
the tour bus operator has turned one of
his old rigs into a traveling dark room
I would say I need that in here for the
past year they've been riding around
western Canada capturing some amazing
Landscapes crystals become an expert on
spotting ideal conditions
I will be using uh walkie-talkie tell
him how the weather is and how about the
cloud is beautiful or not the couple met
in high school right around the same
time Bill got into photography but no
other technique has captured his
imagination quite like this
even your look is the
Sublime
despite all the hard work and some
developing mishaps it's all worth it
when everything comes together even the
door is closed that he will yell at me a
crystal will come to see come to see
this is so amazing
Bill's been too busy building cameras
and converting tour buses to think about
selling any of his work just yet one day
that will happen right now they're still
looking for perfect shots and
fine-tuning a technique that's over 170
years old this all you see is the
picture
every day we will face
problem everybody will be so problem but
I can say every day we are growing for
me it's more beautiful than the
landscape
Jay Durant Global News
wow that is fascinating and that is
global national for this Sunday night
I'm Tracy Tong tonight's your Canada is
the town of ilamor Newfoundland and
Labrador we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching pharah Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
foreign
[Music]